Jennifer this is kind of a team up here
because you guys work on night crawlers
and perhaps it's shared a few other
things so how different was it producing
with people you already knew and
projects who you had a sense of what was
going to end up versus just walking into
something cold like a cold casting call
for a producer of course great ease
we've done we've done Nightcrawler
together but John and I have done three
other films in addition to those two so
five together now and there's a real
shorthand and it's and we we felt so
lucky to get to have Kevin come back
from Nightcrawler and assembled we also
Robert Al's with who shot Nightcrawler
as well James Newton Howard James Newton
Howard yeah so it was it's becomes a
family and and so John did
Denzel Washington was not only a
producer working with Jennifer with this
he was also in there editing we have
very much like Jeff and and his son was
as well right yeah so of how how did
that work it's it's a full you want to
keep the brain toast really small but it
was it was this and it was this great
having his input he he has so many
insights into his character that that we
that we thought we knew but he would
point something out we're like oh this
and that and he's you know he's a
filmmaker himself too so he's done this
before and he's comfortable in the
cutting room he's really good he's
really good in the cutting room and he
can watch himself a lot of actors can't
really watch themselves but he he could
he could so he could watch like he was
watching a third person and be
dispatched like a pro like that and how
is his dad or his son editing his dad it
was Matt was just great having in the
room and yeah you know he did another
another another interesting perspective
and they obviously very close so it was
a four of us and there was really
interesting it's really fun and Kevin
there are of late and and have been so
many movies in the past that were shot
in LA but they weren't identified or
identifiable as LA because you shoot in
Vasquez rocks you want to make believe
it's Mars but this was so
quintessentially LA and it was several
characters of Los Angeles you had rich
Los Angeles which was floating above
poor Los Angeles down on the ground
level and so much of it was downtown how
did you make those
decisions and did you have to do any
persuading with these guys like this is
the place to do it well yeah with any
film you you know we walked the sidewalk
we walked from Romans house to his
office to the courthouse today we figure
out how far is it from Romans office to
the hospital and once you understand the
fabric of Los Angeles it's easy to
really kind of see how it works and you
know and to show Dan and you know all of
us standing there with Robert Ellsworth
we kind of found our or tableau it did
have almost a neo-noir
quality to it when you look at the
street level and what's still in
downtown and the sinister element that
you brought into that there probably
didn't need too much of a push right no
but the thing the funny thing about
downtown is it's going through so much
change and there's so much construction
I think in the one shot of him when he's
on the balcony of the level hotel we
counted like 14 or 15 tower cranes that
night so it's just under constant change
and one thing I really enjoyed about
making this movie was that we were able
to show LA when you see this movie 10
years from now you can see those
buildings are under construction they're
gonna be you know full built so it's
kind of a timeless classic time capsule
Jennifer is it was harder than you
thought you thought oh we're shooting in
LA it'll be easier it'll be cheaper and
then it turns out to be harder than you
thought no really find shooting in LA to
me la is the best city in the world to
shoot and we have the most experienced
crew who are happy to sleep in their own
beds we have we have murmurs of
appreciation from the audience on that
house we have incredible weather for
shooting very consistent it's there's
such great ease I feel great great
privilege to get to shoot in this city
and it's rare and we were beneficiaries
of the tax rebate on the film and that
helped us hugely had we not been we
would have still made it work because
there was nowhere else that we could
what was it shot everything on schedule
of course yeah so of course yeah we
always did no idea how often we hear
something other than that up here so we
run a tight ship
well since you all know one another too
there's no hard feelings except you two
guys at Thanksgiving maybe I don't know
family it's a little difficult we get
along with twins we're fraternal twins
you could tell that right and and we get
along and it's I don't think we never
fight we didn't have one fight we just
we have the same sort of vision for
things so it makes it work very easy how
did the principal character then evolved
how much of it was Denzel Washington's
input did you conceive him as a
character who was perhaps somewhere on
the autism spectrum or is that something
that Denzel Washington said how about if
we do this so I really heavily
underwrite I don't really put many
descriptions of the character or the
setting or any parentheticals of what a
character's feeling so I invite I'm
Nightcrawler and the whole thing was to
get Jake come in and create this
character the same thing here I I I took
myself after Nightcrawler I told myself
off the market for your and wrote this
on spec for Denzel I'd never met him
before and I'd never really written for
an actor before had Denzel not done it I
wouldn't have done the film really would
not have done the film it's just I was
so hand in glove I couldn't conceive of
it and and when Denzel then committed it
started a year-long process before
offenses and after offenses where he
started creating the character every
aspect of the character he always says
from the inside out he has a very
private internal process that he does
not really share what that process is
but it'll start to come with you with
the results and you'll start to see this
person form so right up until a week
before a shooting when I went in to have
a rehearsal with him and he smiled and
he'd ground the gap out of his tooth
teeth which was and that was the few
about it is the first I knew about it
but I'm you're just the level of
commitment for an actor to do that it's
just so incredible I think the last
thing I remember he came up with a
character is two days before shooting he
said I only eat peanut butter sandwiches
over the sink so it was like it was a
chunky or is it creamy you like which
one is this Jeff who's Jeff it was
definitely Jeff it was Jeff but it's
gotten product placement from Jeff but
as soon as I saw the rows of Jeff I knew
a lot about his character so it was was
that you Kevin who brought that to know
you were just man exactly no I think I
think he's door during the rehearsal and
bought store out with all their peanut
butter and it happened to be Jeff
I think that's how we decided on Jeff
because they haven't have enough he
answered that question as we spent days
thinking about it Schiff says it a
Skippy Suey gypsy we tried it with
Skippy and it just didn't work and the
character wasn't coming together there
was also some humor that Denzel
Washington's character brought that
maybe you wouldn't have felt permission
to do otherwise the scene where someone
tells him that William is dead I'm sorry
and he says well why you didn't kill him
where did that come from your conception
of the character or was it the way that
Denzel Washington chose to bring that
line is in the script but Denzel
certainly brought humor the scene where
she calls him up and ask him out a date
hmm uh uh I mean as he's doing it we uh
we're in the cutting room I think we
must have watched that over a hundred
times it was just as funny the hundr
time as it was the first time that we
laughed every time we came here every
time we go by we like laughing and look
at each other like I can't believe
you're laughs and then you're watching
these takes he's like he wore Denzel got
shoes that were two sizes too big which
is why he's always galumphing around and
like anytime he comes into the room he
kind of he would start running he'd like
run into the room like a little kid and
it's just so endearing and it is funny
that's Denzel that stuff Denzel thank
you to all of you thank you for coming
here thank you